So children, suppose you are sitting in a car
and the car is moving forward at a particular speed.
Now let me ask you a general
question, is every part of the car
moving at the same
speed as the car?  Now son, the
answer is no, why not because
when you focus on the wheels of the car, its
wheels are doing pure rolling motion
and because they are doing pure rolling motion, that is
why the lowest part of the wheel
which is in contact with the ground.  It is at
rest for that moment and let me tell you an interesting thing, the
top part of the same wheel is
moving forward at twice the speed of the vehicle. Now this is a very exciting
concept and questions related to this are asked
a lot in NEET.  More come, that is why if you have
any doubt related to it,
in the details in the description, you can understand the concept of pure rolling
very well and
can also know the questions related to it.